so yesterday we talked about Steven
Bannon the former White House chief
strategist US chief propagandist in some
ways an advisor to Donald Trump in his
inner circle Bannon was subpoenaed by
Robert molars special investigation as
well as by a House Intelligence
Committee and Bannon in that ten-hour
marathon interview with the House
Intelligence Committee refused to answer
a whole bunch of different questions and
after the ten hours of interviewing some
of the Democrats on the panel came out
and said yeah you know II we were
frustrated with him he was just not
answering a lot of our questions and I
proposed yesterday when doing that story
that in some way Bannon had been
influenced by the White House to be
quiet on a number of issues and I was
sort of wrong the White House hadn't
gotten to him
past tense they were getting to him in
real time during this ten hours ten
hours of testimony it has been revealed
that during the ten hours of testimony
in front of the house intelligence
committees interview in front of in
front of the House Intelligence
Committee during his interview that
bannon's lawyer was relaying the
questions in real time to a lawyer at
the White House who would say yeah he
can go ahead and answer that one or no
he shouldn't answer that one bannon's
attorney is a guy named bill Burke and
bill Burke during the hearing
was on the phone with a White House
lawyer and the White House lawyer would
decide whether Bannon would or would not
answer any particular question and the
White House told him not shockingly not
to answer any questions related to his
work on the Trump transition team and
not to answer any questions related to
his work in the Trump White House which
is basically the reason he's there
because he was on the transition team
and he was working on at the White House
I guess conceivably it was okay to ask
about bannon's involvement and knowledge
of the Trump so a organization campaign
call it what you will during the
campaign piece and not once he had been
elected and certainly not once he had
been inaugurate
and now it becomes very clear why the
Democrats on the House Intel committee
were so frustrated and this is not a
single-source story the back and forth
that was happening on the phone was
confirmed by a White House official and
by another person familiar with the
interview that took place of course all
speaking on the condition of anonymity
so exactly as we thought every instinct
that sort of surfaces from these
hearings ends up being true including
here that there was an external force
pushing ban and towards not answering
questions we just didn't know that it
was actually someone literally on the
phone with bannon's lawyer during the
interview and in Moeller news so what
one part of bannon's subpoenas requests
to appear was the house Intel committee
ten-hour interview yesterday the other
part is that Robert Muller has has also
or had also subpoenaed Steve Bannon to
testify before a grand jury and the
Associated Press was now able to confirm
that Bannon is going to meet with Robert
Mulder's team instead of appearing
before a grand jury so if the subpoena
was meant to scare Bannon into agreeing
to meet behind closed doors then it
worked if the real goal was to actually
get Bannon in front of a grand jury then
I guess we can say that that failed but
a lot of legal experts saying now you
subpoena him to the grand jury because
you suspect he might not meet with you
behind closed doors unless that's
preferable to being in front of a grand
jury we don't yet know when that's going
to happen but it is going to happen
there's a case to be made here that the
White House and their continued effort
to exert influence over the
investigation is part of the pattern of
obstruction of justice that's being
investigated or to put it another way
the White House is doing whatever it can
to obstruct an investigation into
whether they obstructed justice
previously or at least partially into
whether Donald Trump may have obstructed
justice so long story short nothing
surprising and we're going to have to
wait and see what happens in that
Moeller meeting and what eventually
comes of that meeting as well but I
think
that if anything is becoming
increasingly clear or to put it a
different way because maybe it's not
becoming clear to people like Bannon or
Trump what's becoming an increasingly
common signal from Robert Moeller is
that lying to heat to him and his
investigators is not going to be
tolerated and hopefully people like
Bannon will eventually figure that out
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by brilliant
which is a tremendous online service
that allows you to master interesting
concepts in math science and engineering
by solving fun and challenging problems
and unlike other learning sites when I'm
using brilliant I'm actually learning by
working hands-on with real-world
scenarios and problems you solve
challenging puzzles that have been
carefully designed by expert educators
and professionals from all over the
world and they don't go too fast or too
slow they take you step-by-step through
the topics that you're interested in at
your own pace
one of their principles of learning is
effective learning is active and this
makes a lot of sense to me we all learn
lots of new things in passive ways
watching videos on YouTube for example
which is great I do it all the time but
that can only take you so far and that's
where brilliant comes in don't just
learn by watching learn by doing and you
can get started right now by signing up
for free at brilliant org slash David
Pakman
the first 200 people who visit brilliant
org slash David Pakman will get 20% off
an annual Premium Membership one more
time
brilliant org slash david pakman